en petit serge ce que je savais pas
c'est que ton père était pianiste
à l'époque c'était à pigalle à
belleville
il ya même un 20-6 et pts et aux enfants
de malchance ça c'est pour ça que tu as
fait la chanson comme ça quand habitait
rue chaptal en face de la salle scène
c'est un simon desbiens et du hot club
de france et du hot club de france et tu
rencontrais fréhel dans les rues
un jour je suis revenu sur ma barrows la
croix d'honneur est édité à partir
et beaucoup
et elle qu'est ce qu'elle sent voyant
qu'ils ont je pense qu'on est à fait
deux chansons avant de faire le
poinçonneur c'était nul ne le saura
jamais merde et ça ne vaut pas la peine
non et ça vient enfin il s'est ensuite
bien non métis sont prémonitoires et
chenu ne sera jamais et ça ne vaut pas
la peine d'en parler
et après tu as fait le poinçonneur 164 a
fêté à des capucines c'était avec boby
lapointe et ça s'était passé comme en
bas c'est lui
c'est les métiers qui a ramassé vrai
ouais moi j'étais un peu
mais toutes les pièces voir
c'est un put en ses moyens sur les mots
il appelant ces noms c'est bien
école fouet en 79 tafer le palace
fabrice est maire je te rappelle des
souvenirs est là avec nous rasta et
choristes de marley le chanteur de
touche et roland barthes il avait aragon
ouais mais pas calice il n'aura duré
seriak des morts on les a tous intérêt
toujours là d'accord en 85 casino de
paris
c'était un peu la dernière date a dit
c'est la dernière fois que je fais de la
scène
non je prends mon nom je veux pas nous
faire le coup des adieux de mer 1 tu vas
pas nous faire les adieux tous les
enfants c'est pour les adieux aux
saleuses et non voilà tu nous fais le
génie de gainsbourg s'asseoir dans tous
les formats ca total entendu parler du
portrait chinois
[Musique]
tu t'étais un nazi c'est quoi comme nazi
elle est bonne celle là bum rush et pas
je souhaite que cet homme celui-ci
aurait dîné encore un riff de moi
c'était une infirmité
c'est quoi la vérité bien vite et le
choix
je suis déjà aveugle je veux savoir les
seuls qui ce qui se passe
non ce beau monde et isolde c'est bien
et j'étais été un poison ciguë ci lui
tout de suite tu penses à ça des fois
non
alors je cours je avant
pas trop ah bon j'ai pas d'argent à
l'hemingway le seule arme que tu as chez
toi c'est une seringue quoi et comme tu
la mets sur la table on pense pas que tu
t'en sers vraiment pas certain
je sème a été donnée par le père de jane
carrey la dernière seuls les officiers
blessés avaient droit à cette seringue
et une ampoule de 100 films et
deviennent pompey doit figurer sous
frank l on s'est vraiment fait de bric
et à cette offre
tout ça est très perfide albion est un
accident vous est plus arrivé bien le
hindenburg là le truc nazis qui s'est
scratché sur new york
c'était du rap avant l'heure aujourd'hui
des sites étaient une cicatrice à
pierre sully travail
voilà
thomas chier pour y arriver
avec les grands échanges
mais dans le métier
j'étais le fauche ben ouais maintenant
j'ai eu beaucoup de blé cela me disais
que c'est beaucoup de blessés nous voilà
enfin
ouais je pense que j'ai vraiment j'étais
parfois je suis rouge
non c'est
un grand seigneur un des derniers grands
c'est fermé du 19 sec tout dans les
hautes alpes pour encore voir les jets
privés
c'était bien marré finalement d'accord
j'ai pas fini
ah oui encore quelques bons coups
attirer avec bambou
narré avec lui foute de claques dans la
gueule c'est pas un jury s'est fait un
shampoing également à souvient le fils
de son père lui et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de linars d'études abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu